hello there rejects I am Greg you know
our names that's John John there we go
we got it guys listen we're gonna watch
today a video called drill sergeant
recruit soldiers this is from the
channel the very successful channel
called sounds like pizza
John and I were looking around we've
never seen sounds like pizzas videos
ever and we have no idea what this is
looks like some kind of funny let's play
yeah I don't know I also know kind of 3d
skin animation or something cuz one of
our top reward tiers on patreon whatever
video you requested must definitely do
and put them on the youtubes and today
comes from Tyler hey good buddy Tyler
Hague you pull up a tree on the request
weird [ __ ] Grand Theft Auto 5
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
most fun to play video games
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow that make that makes me wanna do
Let's Plays yeah that what this guy does
it just picks a game and jumps on as a
character and plays live I have no idea
man yeah this was like everything great
and terrible about online gaming all
rolled into one
racism insults but I was just getting to
say whatever the hell you want strangers
online really said videogames that
morning he feels like you'd be such a
fun guy to play with I know you gotta
find uh sounds like pizza or whatever
his name is on Xbox Live or PS network
whatever see if he plays red dead man
it's been a while since I played a video
game right that's people have said
before like do Let's Plays do Let's
Plays and I'm I feel like we could do
funny Let's Plays together if we're
really on it yeah if we're like we're
feeling this kind of energy I feel like
we can do it well usually when I play
games I just get lost and I'm just quiet
I'm away for like at well here's what
we'll do you you'll play the let's plan
I will make the commentary yeah and then
we can switch off a tree so often people
would probably prefer that overall then
you'll get like a full on actual
gameplay and silliness well I love how
he really committed to the the voice of
this character because he was like
playing with earlier me or something
there's a couple times where you hear
like like a loner breaking but majority
of the time he was very very committed
to that he wouldn't like burst out
laughing you could tell every time she
was holding them back from laughing but
that's pretty impressive that you could
commit that whole bringing all your
friends laugh that much it you're just
so committed to this character that's
that's actually really impressive to
commit to that level down from just the
things he was shouting to even than nan
says you know is making yeah I just not
only get a complete character it makes
me want to play some GTA though I had no
idea you could do half of these things
No
had like an airfield and planes you can
fly I think his rock star rock star also
does Red Dead so yeah when it comes to
like the lifestyle the exploration all
those things you just do whatever you
want the more realistic and the worst
things you can do the better the game is
that's what I say alright I'll hop back
on GTA 4 alright our last GTA game I
play alright with Tyler hey thanks so
much for requesting this buddy now that
you have given a ps4 to me I can play
GTA 5 hey get online man see if you can
find sounds like pizza
I mean after playing 40 hours of Red
Dead Redemption - and making it 30% of
the story in soon enough I'll be able to
finally hop on to Spider Man ps4 and
shadow of mordor the other ps4 games
like dad I will graduate to Grand Theft
Auto and then you'll play Devil May Cry
5 right yeah sure game that you're dying
to Betty right that's the one I'm that's
really good right yeah yeah you should
pick that up next
Tyler hope you had a good Christmas and
a good New Year hope you accomplished
some things this year I know that you
recently had got to hang out with your
dad in Vegas went to a strip club did
some blow that's just the way you guys
roll interesting father and son duo I'm
happy for you as long as you're bonding
with your father doesn't matter what
fashion I used to kill people in my pops
all that matters is you're connecting
and feeling the love because if you
don't have that love you could turn into
some kind of psychopath let me tell ya
bonding is all bets are off you can do
whatever you want as long as you're
connecting with a loved one you know we
understand love more than anyone else I
receive it at least once a month guys
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell we'll catch
you on the flippity flippity flippity
flip